Hey look guys my name is Jonah welcome
back to my game engine series so last
time we began our profiling journey by
taking a look at help we could actually
add a timer to our code to see how long
certain functions took to execute check
out that video if you haven't already
and today we're actually going to take
all that time and stuff
rip it out completely transform it so
that we can look at our timing results
in more of a visual way so instead of
just looking at stuff inside I am GUI
please take a look at what we had last
time this is basically what we had we
had all these different functions that
we manually added time as to we added a
little name for them and we were just
able to kind of view all of that data
here and if I kind of just pause it you
can see how long everything here took so
sandbox 2d on update for example was
0.14 1 milliseconds this is great and
this is a really rough way of just
seeing exactly what kind of takes the
time in our application if I go through
my run loop for example and I just add
in different scopes or just in different
functions that that run the coolster for
example application on update you know
would call something like you know layer
on update and maybe I have multiple
layers maybe I have a particular render
queue to go through render commands or
something like that once you build up a
game and once you have an actual
application that does something more
than draws that then just drawing like a
checkerboard background with a red and
blue box which we will get to eventually
this is really easy and you can really
drill that down like for example you
know you look at layer on update ok
layer on top that takes 10 milliseconds
that's quite a lot what does that call
which layer takes the most time how does
that break down you can keep drilling
into that call stack down into kind of
that call tree and actually place these
timers everywhere and then see
everything that's a great strategy I'm
not gonna lie like that's not completely
that's not bad that's not terrible at
all that's a really good easy way to do
that you don't rely on any other tools
if you do something like that like you
don't need any profilers that's fine
there's no issue with that the issue
here though is that we have that that
capability to actually do that right I
could just take that macro that we made
and put it everywhere but viewing all of
this data right now and I am gooey isn't
great for example like I mean I could
stop this at any time by clicking on and
then
actually pause basically take a look at
these values but I don't want to see
that I want to see a visual
representation of the history of
everything that was recorded I don't
just want to see every frame kind of it
updating right and seeing what's up nor
I want to see everything in a visual way
and I think that like looking at
profiles visually like this looking at
all these benchmarks of Italy it's
probably the best way to do it for sure
now there are profiling tools like
visual Studios built in profiler which I
probably will make a video on in the
future but I don't like to rely on that
as my only source of profiling data I'm
not gonna say that it's bad you should
use it it's by far the easiest thing
that you can just do that with any
running program right just literally
just open up the riddles to your
profiler and see how they everything
tastes it's a really quick and dirty way
to get results out and it's pretty
robust it's it's it's not bad but this
is a completely cross-platform
cross-device cross tool set way of doing
things because it's kind of integrated
with the hazel engine and I'm a strong
believer of that I like to be rather
independent when it comes to things like
this because just from experience
knowing that you know maybe you're
running on an Android device sometime in
the future and it doesn't support like
visual studios profile just cannot work
with it yet maybe it's a new device
maybe it's just you know it's just not
kind of compatible with the platform
that you're currently running on you
know what if it's a bill that you've
shipped off to someone do you really
want to download video studio who cook
it up with all of the symbols and then
do all of that stuff like that's a lot
of work you know you might not be in a
situation where you could use that I
talked about a lot about that in the
previous episodes but I want repeat
myself too much but the idea is I'm a
strong believer of having this kind of
tool built into the engine and you'll
see that as this series goes on I like
to that there's a lot of tools that I
like to build into the engine even
though strictly speaking you could rely
on third-party tools for things like
that like for example you know why build
a lot of graphics debugging tools if you
can use something like Nvidia inside or
render doc right why well because
sometimes those might not come through
for you the same way that your own tech
might because it's a lot closely kind of
more closed
integrated with your own engine anyway
let's not talk too much about that so
what we want to do is basically
visualize this data now I put up a video
specifically about how you can kind of
do this visual benchmarking thing in C++
I'll have it linked up there make sure
that you check it out if you haven't
already seen it because that is like a
18 minute video that like literally from
scratch net sales loss application with
no other code at all takes a look at how
we can actually build up this system and
I wrote a bunch of code in that episode
oh it wasn't only a episode but in that
video I wrote a bunch of code I made a
gist out of it put it on github we're
gonna literally copy and paste that gist
and then integrate it into hazel so that
was kind of the whole point and I in the
future I actually want to continue on
with doing kind of I guess videos in
that style so what I'll do is I'll make
like a standalone video where I'm just
like okay he has a deep dive of looking
at you know not in a like batch
rendering or something like that riding
or Kanchan let's just say for example
right I'll kind of have a video stand
Alone's for that because that way anyone
who wants to integrate it in their own
engine anyone who's not following along
with hazel or the game engine series
doesn't need to deal with all of the
confusion of okay well great this guy
Cherno is integrating this batch
rendering into his engine which has a
billion other functions and a billion
like a completely different structure
than I'm used to I want to know how
batch rendering actually works for
example right so that's why I like
making standalone videos because they
just tend to help a lot more people and
they're a lot clearer than kind of
having to look at something like hazel
and then integrated financial because
there's kind of two steps to almost
everything we do here in hazel step one
is what is this technology what is this
technique what are we actually doing
what is this structure and then once we
know that once we know how it works once
we know that we want it how do we
integrate it into hazel there's always
kind of the kind of the understanding
and the integration part and so I want
to make the game management series a lot
more about integration and then I want
to make standalone videos about actual
kind of implementation will say or
actual on inner understanding and
teaching so hopefully that makes sense
anyway I don't want to talk too much
make sure you check out the videos I've
linked up there specifically that one
about visual benchmarking because we're
gonna be just taking her from that our
goal today is just gonna be a very very
version of kind of what we achieved in
that video but inside hazel and then I
think next time we'll go through and
actually discuss how to use that kind of
instrumentation time and the whole
instrumental class that we'll take from
that gist and integrated properly
throughout the whole engine because
they're just going to be too much stuff
to discuss in this episode first of all
want to thank all the patrons that made
this series possible Pedro my full-size
tutor knows the best way to help support
this series it wouldn't be here without
those people so I'm really thankful to
everyone there if you like this series
if you like what you see right now then
go to patreon and pledge at least a
little bit because that being able to
kind of do that is what lets me do this
full-time currently like YouTube and
like hazel and all that stuff is my
full-time job so all of my kind of
income I guess is coming from things
related to that which is kind of scary
in a way because you know I could just
disappear any moment and there's no kind
of stability but I'm willing to kind of
take that risk and to work on that
because I'm really passionate about this
technology I really want to make the
best videos on YouTube to do with game
engine programming and just get like
game development I guess and all the
tech behind that and I you know I'm this
too many ideas in my head right now that
I all want to get them all done but it's
kind of hard to this so much to do and
anyway the point is if you like what you
see here and you want to see more of it
then please help to spoil the series to
get access to the 3d version of hazel
which I haven't actually worked on in a
while but I'm gonna get back to that
soon there's a Vulcan version of hazel
which I'm working on which I probably
will release probably get a lab or
something like that just cause it's a
bit more lenient with some features that
actually want and then there's also I'm
trying to do weekly dev vlog videos
specifically about patreon exclusive
videos really easy to get into that it's
like three dollars a month and you get
access to all of them the whole backlog
as well as any new one that comes out
and that's gonna just cover what I kind
of do all week because I want to kind of
stay accountable to what I'm actually
doing all week and plan my works better
and so that's gonna help with that
anyway let's dive into this code let's
take that instrumental card and get it
integrated into hazel so just going
through our current code that we have we
had this timer class this is basically
the gist of the timer class is funny
that I say
because it's literally August but what I
have here let me just make this a little
bit smaller so we can see all of it what
I have here is HS I'll link this in the
description of the video or in fact if
you go to that visual profiling or
visual benchmarking video that I made in
the into the top right corner you'll
actually that video has a link to this
so just go there if you're interested in
this visit the code what this is is like
a basic instrumentation for viola what
this does is basically it gives you a
static class called instrumental which
writes out into a JSON file basically
every function or every scope that you
profile and then that way we can load it
into something called chrome tracing
which is this little tool that comes
with Google Chrome it's actually at
anything that's based on chromium it
actually will have this as well so I
think opera and some other browsers
probably will have that as well so you
can just go to kind of chrome tracing
like that and then you'll just be
created with this kind of tool and you
can drop in a JSON file into that tool
JSON file that will be generated by this
class and you will be able to visualize
like a timeline of all of the different
timings that you've actually gathered
throughout the run time of your
application so that's kind of the idea
again if you want more info on that just
check out that links video then I made
but yeah like we're literally just gonna
copy this probably up to like here and
then if we go to solution Explorer and
then hazel core this probably isn't
exactly a core thing I don't really like
I might make a folder called debug
because this this is fairly debug
specific in fact I will make a folder
called debug the reason is you should
never use this in the distribution of
your application like this is something
that is definitely for development
purposes only its header only as well so
you can literally just like you should
be able to just paste
I used it and it should just compile and
it should work and everything should be
fine so that's what you can do what I'm
gonna do is because again this code is
something that we just kind of compiled
once and we forget about in fact we
don't need this like at all
I might write some macros here first but
you can easily just include this into
your PC H in fact that's probably the
best thing to do so what I'll do is I
will include it into my PC H and then
I'm going to the button and then I'm
going to do and again you could easily
just shut off the whole thing if you you
know you're like you could put the whole
thing behind it if they're for something
like that
if you really really didn't want it to
be compiled at all in distribution
builds but it's probably easier to still
have that code but just you know shut
off any kind of usage of amazing macros
so what we want to do and the way this
works you really should check out that
video again if you're sure than that but
basically what I like to do is H set
profile right so if H said profile is
turned on and this is something that
again where you want to set this up you
probably want to make some kind of and
we will probably do this in the future
make some kind of configuration file
that kind of just has all of the macros
that you've configured a certain way if
we check out what was it like total age
right like we have a lot of these macros
here we've got enable assert stuff like
that you don't want this scattered
around all of your application obviously
because if I want to for example change
the change whether asserts or enable
change where the profiling is enabled I
have to go hunt a bunch of files to
figure that out I don't want that at all
there should be like a central file like
it's called like core config or
something like that don't H that just
has like you know you know stuff like
profiling and define profiling one you
know it's fine
perfectly but anyway define you know
asserts one or some high-back just so
that you actually know what's up in a
single file so that's something that you
should do um what I'm gonna worry about
that just yet
but if a set profile so if profiling is
enabled then what I'm gonna do is write
a macro that says page said begin well
we'll probably say a said profile ok
what's the actual map are going to be
cold let's see so H said H said profile
function right so H that profile
function is gonna be for functions will
also have profiles stored so I guess
profile P concessioners fine so H said
profile will be kind of the beginning
that's what you kind of expect will have
an end session as well and as you can
see profiling disabled these will all
just result in being absolutely nothing
at all because we don't want you to be
we don't want them to get compiled at
all
so sessions going to need a name and
session probably isn't functions they're
not going to need a name and profile
scope will okay so that's what we end up
with and then this will simply just be
let's see so we need to put this between
behind the hazal namespace so namespace
hazal we go down here there we go
and then we'll just do hazal so we'll
kind of write these the same way that we
did with logged at h what we basically
just had this right so hazel
instrumental begin session i think and
then name and i guess we will probably
so this will output to a file i think so
instrumental begin session so that's not
that's not static quad fix it up but
yeah we have a file path here so what i
will do is probably force this to be
written to a file path so name and file
path will go into here and then i think
this is just instrumented yet don't
begin session so instrument to get will
just create a static instance like that
and then return it which is fine
we'll just do the same
in here for and session sir and
obsession with I think we need anything
for that because we can only have one
active session yep
and then profile function will basically
do what profile skirt does I've got in a
minute
I guess I'll fill this out it doesn't
really matter but this is just to avoid
killed by compiler warnings with macros
being used for the incorrect number of
arguments it'll still compile there even
if we did have the wrong amount of
arguments here because you can really
put anything you want into a mapper
okay so profile scopes so this is the
meat of everything so this will just
basically start up and instrumentation
time off so instrumentation timer will
have to give it a name now you probably
want to append this with line or
something like that to give a unique
name I'll have to test this out because
I saw nothing point out on the comments
the hash hash doesn't really work with
MS PC potentially you might need to
write another mapper which basically
just like you know some kind of
combination thing that basically likes
to like combine things kind of like that
because like there are certain macro
tricks that you need to know if a visual
studio and I always look them up and
then use them and then forget about them
so I think assertions
probably need to use them we don't
really have a good assertion we need to
revisit a sessions at some point because
they're not very robust and I was
working on hazel dev recently and I just
realized that asserts can't even be used
with no message like you have to write
an assert with a message otherwise it
doesn't compile which wasn't great so I
had to kind of refactor the whole assess
system and I in in that time I had to
use a bunch of hacks to get around MSP
sees macro processing but anyway so this
might not work is my point like this
might actually our goal here is to kind
of when we use this right when we use a
set profile scope right let's just say
if we were to use it twice like this so
you know I'll pull this like a and then
we'll have another one which is like B
right so at the moment this wouldn't
compile the reason being that what this
does obviously is it would create well
if we didn't have the line it would just
create this right and then it will try
and make it again but then obviously
they're both full-time and that means
that we have to save variables our goal
is to basically take the line number
which is like 108 in this case appended
here so we have timer 108 and then this
would be called timer 109 and then you
can see we get a kind of unique name
that's the goal of why we want to use
this whole line thing to begin with but
again it might not concatenate those two
strings correctly so we'll see well this
actually results in and we can do that
by just pre-processing to a file anyway
um let's get on with this so H that
profile function will basically do
profiles guard but ill use the func cig
which is a function signature as the
name so function signature gives us
basically the complete name of a
function so if a void stopped it would
give us something like void
see that hole because it also gives us
the calling convention void and then
stop sorry stop and then void for the
parameters because they're on them if
there were parameters you know it would
give us the parameter arguments like
this so this actually oh and also would
give us the name space so it would be
like hazel instrumentalist and obviously
so this is basically what it would give
us which is kind of nice to have a name
like that automatically generated there
is also one called function these are
all kind of built-in mappers in to in I
think they're in the civil standard so
there should be on all compilers in fact
yet they're definitely all compilers but
I'm not sure if they're strictly either
standard or not but anyway the point is
this would give us just I think hazel is
Ren to stop I'm not sure if you giving
us all the namespace info for it just
gives us it should right so maybe it'll
give us this which is not great because
we don't know which overloaded is so if
we have multiple stop functions with
different written like what kind of
different return types but if we have
different arguments for example we
wouldn't know which function it was so
having the func seek right the function
signature just gives us a little bit
more kind of precision as to which
function it is right
giving us a more verbose name I guess
for the function okay anyway so this is
what we end up with that looks pretty
good to me again this is suspicious
we'll investigate that but I think
everything else looks pretty good
okay so this is it profiling is enabled
what I'll do is I'll just enable it like
that for now for testing
I'll just have this across because I
like to really just fight me on that
um okay cool so I think that's it that
looks pretty good to me for a first pass
okay so now we can get rid of this timer
that we have here and profile scope as
well what does get rid of everything
that we kind of used here which means
all this kind of profile result stuff
gone and then so profile scope will
replace with just H said profile
function right and we don't need this a
paddle H set profile function will be on
I'm GUI render as well we can do on
event but doesn't really matter and then
we did we actually did profile Scorpio
so I guess I'll do a set profile scope
all of these things and they should work
it's saying that uh yeah see that
doesn't I don't like the way this looks
here it might not really work anyway
it's saying that it okay so of course I
forgot to pass in the name so this is
what we pass in the name so now this
should probably be better because we
obviously need to actually construct it
with a name okay good um and the other
thing we need to do obviously is begin
session and an session
so that is difficult to decide where you
want that entry point potentially is a
good place to do that
um what I'll do is he'll get rid of this
initialize log and also hello we don't
need when paint this what I'll do is
it's quite common for us to so create
application return new sound box pushes
layers and stuff this is like the
initialization part and then this is
obviously the wrong part and this is
obviously the shutdown parts so what we
can do
is just add a little H that begin that
I've set profile begin session this will
kind of be the startup session which we
can you know put it into heavy profiles
JSON and then we'll have the runtime
version which is heads up for a file of
long time Jason and then we'll have a
shot down one as well right so we kind
of a profiling everything yeah all the
different stages in two separate files
so that if we wanted to check out the
kind of startup performance and how long
it takes to load everything we can do
that but also we can obviously do the
runtime separately so this is basically
what we are not with and I'm kind of
split this up so we have kind of our
begin session for the creation which is
startup and all the it's basically
everything that in this case would run
in on attach right
which for other things like anything in
sandbox up for example you know on
attach was doing quite a lot of stuff so
like all of this stuff right
well actually the constructor was doing
this which is basically the same as I'm
- because it's gonna be running over
here before the leg gets pushed I think
so again that would all be stuff that we
poured into this hazal profile startup
data dot JSON and then yeah this this
runtime stuff everything in the runtime
would get pushed into that which is like
a whole kind of rendering loop and
everything and then shutdown again would
also be recorded separately into a
separate file now you again you probably
want to change this to be the name of
your application you know when you pop
when you create an application when you
include this entry point file into your
file into your main CPP file you
probably want to customize certain
things this is stuff that we anyone can
add in the future I'm not gonna worry
about it too much for now we'll just
keep it as this hazal profile well a lot
to keep things simple okay this should
now work let's just run this compile it
and run it and see what happens
yeah so we got a bunch of disciplines
I was gonna say we got a bunch of
compile error messages because of course
I forgot to get rid of that entire I'm
GUI block of code that we shouldn't have
gotten rid of um let's see if we get
anything now okay good it's running okay
cool so it seems to be running
everything seems fine to me let's just
close this and see if we got our
profiles and if everything worked out
successfully okay so here we are inside
the sandbox directory here we have hazel
profile rug time shutdown and startup so
we have all these you can see the
runtime one is significantly larger
which is always we would expect since
it's a running application if we now
open up chrome tracing and we take a
look at run time which is probably the
only one with actual data then you
should see a visual profile which is
pretty cool so if we kind of zoom in
here then we can see everything that
happens and these controls are a little
weird by the way they look kind of
smooth and weird not really used to this
this is weird and my ws keeps on working
have I done so anyway when I keep up on
it or anyway the point is yeah this is
super super laggy and weird anyway so we
have you can see sandbox on update for
example which shows that this particular
on update function you know two point
three to five milliseconds and that was
the actual sandbox on update we have
camera controller on update that it
calls we have this renderer prep which
is a specific kind of I guess scope that
I profiled and then we have render a
drawer so you can see how cool this is
right being able to see all of this
stuff visually and then we obviously
have what's this this is on item GUI
render which gets called after then we
have a huge break and then we have the
next frame so this is pretty cool right
we're able to see this stuff visually
now instead of kind of you know all kind
of running real-time inside I'm GUI so
definitely very cool now obviously we
want to go through an instrument our
code a lot more which basically means we
want to add these profile functions
everywhere not just in kind of the
sandbox application because that way you
can see that we
we get to see certain kind of sections
here but yeah you can kind of see with
the point here there's that camera
controller on update that we added in
kind of manually and then that's
followed by sandbox on update okay and
you will notice that sometimes I think
it's happened here well we're kind of
getting into that more when we get into
a more but yeah like so these two have
the exact same start time and the reason
that's happened because we've like the
timer essentially isn't precise enough
to know the difference between like
we've asked the timer for the current
time twice in succession very quickly
and it hasn't been able to update the
time so we get identical start times
which is not correct because clearly in
real life you know sandbox to do an
update happen slightly before camera
control an update so that's happened
here right you can see a side profile
function the start time which happens
immediately if we were good edge that
profile function goes to purpose Kirk
goes to instrumentation time and then we
have a start point here we ask it what
the current time is by just running the
snail function and then getting that
time point we've basically gone ahead
and cold now twice quickly right like
that because that's that's the code that
runs here and then straight off till we
do that we ask it to profiles curve
which again starts a new instrumentation
timer and gets the current time point
the starting time point now what we need
to do is either use a high resolution
time or something like a platform
specific timer like query performance
counter or some other that will probably
be good enough or you'll need to write a
little system that basically ensures
that every time you ask it for the
current time it gives you like a unique
value which is something that we might
do just because it's quick and dirty and
it gives us everything we want without
having to you know write specific time
as peplau for my name and that isn't
guaranteed to 100% walk anyway i problem
that everything's looking good it so
that's kind of gonna wrap it up for
today next time i want to go through the
rest of our code base and see what we
can kind of litter this stuff into
there's not too much interesting data to
look at now keep in mind that like they
probably won't be interesting data to
look at at the stage
Hazel's development well will fill this
out a lot more obviously but in general
right you know this takes point for
milliseconds like everything is quite
fast and a frame is significantly longer
than that probably because it's trying
to do vsync or something like that you
can see their frame from here to here is
about 13 milliseconds if you had to
actually do it from maybe the start of
the frame to the start of the frame you
can see yeah 14 milliseconds could be
about 16 which is probably you know 60
FPS which is basing so that's probably
what's happening but in general that is
our visual profile which is pretty cool
I think if we look at the start up or
shutdown we're not going to see anything
at all because we have an obviously out
of any instrumentation into there
whatsoever so we'll definitely fill
those out as well in the next video
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video please hit the like button if you
did don't forget to help support the
series and my youtube channel on patreon
and next time we'll kind of use all of
this stuff that we've integrated into
our engine now true actually get some
meaningful data data out of it and that
way in the future one would do some
things we'll be able to actually see how
fast things took I will see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]